walk in to this video I'm playing yogurt
yet again Grand Master Eric LeBron what
is he doing come on ya know I and we
have a history of the Kings gambit
actually has played the Kings gambit a
number of times against me oh it's funny
okay we this time the exchange the Rue
La Paz exchange my score by the way is
five out of 14 against em five wins nine
losses fc3 here it's a very uncommon
move normally white is trying to review
it there should be seven bye-bye just
capturing which GM didn't try okay I'll
just notice mmm yeah an interesting an
interesting position here out of this
delayed or dissolve the sir willow pass
exchange with them white having a
complete porn center a perfect porn
center and black having two bishops it's
probably quite okay for Adam nothing
that i would terribly fears like but
white is Saudi comfortable how should I
play this not easy I would like to to
play f5 really at some point maybe am
provoked some some it's a move of the e
porn so that my light squared Bishop can
actually do something maybe also 96
Bishop f6 also be possible investing
moves
if i call now 96 is probably even
playing Bishop to e6 and Quincy to is
directed against a five interesting not
easy not quite sure how to how I should
play this my myspace disadvantages is a
slight problem running he also might
play something with d5 p.m. maybe I
should actually do that if he takes to
be capture with the pawn it it should be
a fairly solid structure and have maybe
night f4 yeah maybe let's look solid
it's not so nice to give up the bishop
power but probably there is no big big
choice iam ok is plain it2 back maybe
here oh no then you can play in five but
I have to ship before ok and that's no
problem
okay maybe maybe I can relief yet some
some pressure with exchanges and maybe
try to play against the upon a check I
don't matter let's roop d8 bishop c8
something like that is okay
two minutes sometime about a minute down
on the clock you see a ring at the g7
pawn possible but let's say night h5 i
have 3g five that's not not a big
problem i wonder if i should at some
point maybe place c 5 i'm if they have
Queen if I I can I should do that maybe
takes takes Knight age 5 25 okay so I'm
trying to try to change the pawn
structure here if he goes defiled I have
Queenie five possibly be five not quite
sure that his cluster of pieces here is
so great when Queen when when the pawn
structure has changed ok once to only
change the structure does somewhat more
favorable way for him but ok b5 belongs
in there any way I can also play c4 in
d5 now if I want not sure that I want
but I could do it
hmm not quite clear not sure about this
if I really need to do this move
yeah I'm not not sure it's very tricky
to play can maybe get the night back to
f3 mb525 i think is ok ty morning yeah i
need to i need to to change and change
the plane IAM my bishop is wrong on b7
now and I need to get it over here to
this diagonal to e6 to see 836 and at
the same time here prepare the beep on
push I want this counter play here on
the B file and this is all protected I
might you might have have a direct
meeting attack here on the GF are not
seeing it though at the moment if I go
here maybe f6 okay i don't i don't have
the time to to calculate it
going for group III a possible for
counter play rook g3 is looking for then
group g2 unfortunately check
okay I'm worse but not not totally easy
no check probably it's really bad
threatening Bishop f5 check
check I'm just better now I think maybe
not now of course play on time as usual
nobody's ever going to show any any
level of fair play check okay drawn okay
yeah this was a very tight escape of
course I was losing here I guess ok
computer saying it's equal here are
interesting yeah very tough very tough
middle game here with little time on the
clock hits here 45 is strong do you find
the strong yeah very tough i can analyze
any position here and probably find some
stuff maybe this wasn't too bad i mean
i'm sort of blocking here and i have
this this counter play which i went for
I was losing the age porn or here
Queenie 7s winning yeah the little the
little tricks with with the smooth funny
yeah okay it's it's a blitz game what
can you do I was hoping for this counter
play on the B file but it looks very
dangerous his initiative on the kingside
very dangerous the ante aruch bb3 seems
to be I wanted to play this originally
but then I was suddenly seeing this me
when I thought oh k f6 is going to be
very problematic but this is a good
reply it seems given by the engine check
check
96 is a very funny computer move which I
to be honest fail to understand takes as
this one hmm this idea then f7
interesting seems to be good for word
chat yeah okay well here I just needed
to move move move check and I'm
certainly lost ya plus 5 m from white
this was the final deny idea which she
check ignored yeah and here I mean check
it was very difficult to so play any
decent moves but was trying to play for
a king of six noise good right right
here was he was mostly trying to win on
time not looking for good news f60 e6
maybe winning and not clear though yeah
yeah okay I need to apologize yes i will
thought in the in the heat of the battle
you should take a five and so here take
a four but of course this is nonsense
rookie five is perfectly right it's
perfectly right though check no i need
to get rid of the bond with two seconds
on the clock yeah it's always tough
against him here around this this middle
game here was very very interesting many
possibilities can i play c4 should i put
the bishop on b7 at some point g6 I
wasn't sure
but the move interesting there was one
one particular moment here something
like d5 I should have thought about this
is really good the problem is that this
natural response is basically losing
upon yeah and it's not so clear what
what else is why doing if he does that
can even think about this move and then
getting d5 back later yeah okay right a
very tough fight thanks for watching